- Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining me.
I've just quickly scrolled
through the participants,
and I see some people I
haven't seen in a while
and would love to see again
and some of our colleagues.
So, hello, all of you.
I wish we were here in person,
but this is our current situation.
I am going to give a
very short introduction
to somebody I suspect many of you know,
which is the wonderful Michael Steinlauf,
so as not to take up too much of our time.
So, Michael Steinlauf is
a veteran of many things,
of Poland in the 1980s,
of Columbia in 1968,
of revolution, of Jewish revival,
and a professor of East
European Jewish History.
We are here today to talk
about a very special book
that has just come out in English
called, "This Was Not America."
The book is in a very particular genre,
which doesn't really exist
on this side of the Atlantic,
but is in fact one of my favorite genres.
In Polish, you call it a wywiad rzeka,
the kind of river interview
which is a long dialogue conversation.
In fact, really a kind of
series of conversations
woven together, generally
between two thinkers,
you know, that turns into a book
that's not in monological
form, but in dialogical form.
And this book goes through
a kind of extraordinary autobiography.
And at the center of this is a question
about the Holocaust and
Polish-Jewish history.
I will not take up any more time.
I will just say that the
book that is beneath the book
we're going to talk about today
called "Bondage to the
Dead," was one of the books
that had the strongest influences on me
when I was a graduate
student in the 1990s.
I'll tell you how this is going to go.
What I'm going to first
ask Professor Steinlauf,
ask Michael to do, is to
talk a bit about the book,
how it came to be in the
autobiographical narrative,
and then I will prompt
him with some questions.
And then I would like to save time
for those of you in the
audience to ask questions.
The format for this is
that chat is disabled,
but the Q&A, Inessa tells me, is enabled,
so if you have questions,
please type them in the Q&A,
and I will do my best to scan through them
and choose as many as we have time for.
And Michael's a very friendly person.
I'm sure he will try his best
to answer everything honestly.
Okay, with that, I'm going
to turn that over to Michael
and have him talk to you, tell
you a bit about this book,
how it came into existence,
and what it's about.
The book is called,
"This Was Not America,"
and it's a kind of tangled web
of Polish-Jewish American history,
a tangle through Polish-Jewish
American history.
- Okay, so I can't talk about this book
because it refers to another book
that was published 25 years ago,
and that is "Bondage to the Dead,"
Poland and the memory of the Holocaust.
I have to refer to it
because this book arose,
the current book arose as a
direct consequence of that book.
So, that book was,
well, we have to put
Elżbieta Janicka in here.
Elżbieta Janicka, my colleague, my friend,
who, at a certain point
some years ago texted me,
saying, "I've read your book seven times."
And then she says, "It's
unbelievable, I love it.
It's absolutely true. And at
the same time, it's bullshit."
Now that book, "Bondage to the
Dead," poses the idea that...
See, I was trying to, at
that time 25 years ago,
deal with the fact that how
do you deal with the fact
that years or months
after the end of the war,
people who had hidden Jews
still had to hide them.
What the hell was that? What is that?
I couldn't understand that.
And so I went to the only
place I felt I could go to
is Robert Jay Lifton and
his notion of trauma.
And he was talking about, you know,
things like Hiroshima and so on.
So, this notion of trauma was
then contested by Elżbieta,
who said, "No, no, no,
no. It's not trauma."
And so we started a conversation.
And that conversation
was a kind of, you know,
as Marcy says, it was a wywiad rzeka.
It covered everything.
And it covered all parts of my life, too.
It's everything.
It's partly biographical,
and it's partly, you know, political.
It's partly me arguing
with her about all of this,
and about the notion of whether trauma,
first of all, I mean,
mostly, is the proper word,
is the proper concept for
what it is I had encountered.
And she argued, "No, it's not trauma.
It's just anti-Semitism,
basically." (chuckling)
And if people ask me about that,
I can talk about that a little bit.
But there's many different
directions to go in,
and it was exciting to be able
to look at all of these things.
So, I'm open to, you know, I'll just stop.
And Marci, I mean, do you have something?
I mean, if there's something
that I should have explained
right from the get-go, tell me.
I'll do it.
I'm really open to
whatever, I mean, you know.
- Maybe I'll just throw
a couple things out
for the audience, for the people
who are not already in the
midst of this conversation.
Michael is the child of
survivors of the Holocaust.
Each of his parents had
been married before the war.
You know, each of his parents
lost families during the war,
met and married after the war
as kind of lone survivors.
Michael was born in France after the war.
They soon after moved to Brighton Beach.
He grew up in a Polish-Jewish
community in Brighton Beach,
speaking Polish, hearing
stories about the war.
He realizes then Brighton
Beach is not actually America,
it's something else.
Everybody speaks Polish and
constantly talks about this war.
- The little environment
that I found myself in as a
child was that, but mainly,
and this is not the
Brighton Beach of today.
Because beginning in the '70's,
all these Russians moved in,
and now everything's Russian here.
This is before.
Yeah, all right, go ahead.
- So, this is childhood in Brighton Beach.
You then grow up,
you have a difficult
relationship with your parents.
You grow up, you go to
Columbia. You're there in 1968,
You're occupying the building.
There's scenes right out
of "Strawberry Statement,"
if anybody remembers that book.
You're a revolutionary,
you move to Seattle,
you try to overthrow
the American government
with a kind of, you know, eclectic mix
of Marxists and anarchists
and anti-racists and feminists
and, you know, Black Panthers.
You go on the run for a while.
So, you have this very,
you're the generation of '68.
You have a very 1968 experience.
You're a revolutionary, you're
a social justice activist.
You go back later, you
know, get a graduate degree
in East European Jewish History.
Your native language is Polish.
You learn Yiddish, you know,
as a way into this history
that was both yours,
but somehow not quite,
because your parents come from
the assimilated
Polish-speaking intelligentsia.
And then you end up,
after your parents have died,
you know, relatively young,
in Poland at the end of
martial law around 1983
coming into this scene of
trying to understand the world
that your parents came from,
you know, in a Warsaw in which
there are not very many Jews.
But there's a handful of them
who are largely the children
of Polish-Jewish communists
who wanted to have nothing
to do with being Jews,
who are in the midst of
rediscovering that they are Jews.
And this then becomes your
entry into Poland, you know,
and your attempt to understand this world
that disappeared before
you were born, you know,
but that is not gone without a trace
because through the cracks,
there are constantly things bubbling up
from this world that was killed.
- Marci, that's wonderful.
Do I need to say more?
- Thank you. So, this is my
little summary of the book.
There are a few things in the
book I'd like to talk about.
- Please.
- But maybe I'll start with the one
that's probably most
important for our audience,
which has to do with this
book, "Bondage to the Dead."
And that book came out in 1997.
It came out when I was living in Warsaw,
and I don't remember how
I got a copy in English.
Maybe you brought me a copy in English.
Somehow somebody gave
me a copy of the book
when I was in Warsaw and
it was not yet easy to get.
- It may have been me.
- It may have been you,
it might have been Cecile.
- What year was it?
- It was '97. It was the
year the book came out.
- Okay. But I wasn't...
I don't think. Oh, it doesn't matter.
- You were there briefly,
but various people were
coming back and forth.
In any case, what this book was about,
you know, was precisely the question
that I had become obsessed with
after two to three months
of living in Warsaw,
which is that, you
know, the Jews are gone,
but there's an obsession with them.
You know, they're gone
and they're not gone.
And there's not only
an obsession with Jews
on behalf of, you know,
a handful of Americans
trying to work through
their identity complexes,
there's also an obsession with the Jews
who are no longer there
on behalf of Poles.
And this absence of the Jews,
and what has happened to the Jews
has clearly deeply inflected, you know,
and weighed upon everything else
that is happening in Poland.
You know, and so I came there in the '90's
and I'm looking at, there's
all this anti-Semitic graffiti.
There are Stars of David
hanging on gallows.
There are people selling
anti-Semitic books
and "Protocols of the Elders of Zion"
alongside, you know,
books about "Star Wars"
in Polish translation on the street.
- My favorite was a pickup
truck with its back open,
and on one side was a bunch
of raw meat, you know,
that they were selling discounted,
and on the other side was
what you said, you know?
- Yeah, the juxtaposition
was kind of extraordinary,
because Poland was just opening up.
- Yeah, on the one hand that
and on the other hand that,
so, you know, it was a crazy moment.
But I was there, now, are
you talking about '79 now?
- No, no, I'm talking about '97.
- '97. Right.
- I'm talking about '97.
You were there much...
- When I got there, it wasn't like that.
When I got there, things
were softer and gentler,
and it wasn't until, you know,
it was a very different world.
- Yeah, I got there just as
lots of people in the '90's
were kind of rediscovering
that they might be of Jewish origin,
that their grandparents were communist,
that perhaps their parents
were Solidarity activists.
Maybe their parents
even had them baptized,
because at that time,
to have your child baptized
during the time of Solidarity
when Wojtyła was the patron of solidarity,
was a sign of freedom.
And now they were discovering
that maybe they really had Jewish roots.
It was right when Kostak Gebert,
who was one of the people
who was important for you
when you came in the '80's,
had started this new magazine,
Midrasz, you know, in Polish.
And Kostak was, is one
of the most important
underground journalism
Solidarity activists,
who then after, in the '90's,
became Poland's most important
foreign correspondent
in Bosnia during the War
of Yugoslav Succession.
And also one of the most important actors
in the Jewish revival,
trying to understand what
it meant to be Jewish.
And there was this magazine
called Midrasz that still exists
that he began to edit in 1997.
- Does it still exist? I heard it closed.
- Oh, it may have closed.
I thought it still existed.
- During the last year, it was gone.
- Oh, that would be sad.
In any case, it was basically
aimed at closet Jews.
And in the second issue, there
was a half-page advertisement
that said, "Do you have Jewish roots?"
"Czy masz zydowskie
korzenie?" You remember this.
"Is it a secret?" You
know, "Is it a problem?
Or have you been afraid to
talk to your husband or wife,
perhaps your children?"
And it goes on to advertise
a confidential hotline.
And it says, "Zapewniamy dyskrecję."
"We guarantee confidentiality."
- Just like other
confidential (indistinct)
- Exactly, exactly.
Just on that model.
- You know, "Do suspect
you're gay?" I mean...
- Right.
- "Do you suspect something
that you can't...?"
And it's an amazing.
We have to understand, you
know, what does it mean,
you know, that being
Jewish takes that form,
the revelation that one is of Jewish roots
has to be approached in
such a crazy, crazy way?
- It was right after that came out
when I actually went to see Kostak,
who I didn't even know at the time,
and said, "Is this a joke?"
And he said, "No, it's not a
joke. This is very serious.
And we get a lot of phone calls."
And I thought, "What is this about?"
And that's when your book came out,
and "Bondage to the Dead" was about,
and was about what are these complexes
and layer after layer after layer,
clearly having to do
with a lot of repression,
you know, a lot of trauma,
you know, a lot of kind of
hints of Freud here and there.
There were things that you
were trying to figure out.
Why is Poland so haunted?
Why are Poles so haunted?
You know, why is there this
obsession with the Jews?
And is it love, and is it hate?
And is it guilt, and was it, you know,
participation or was it
passivity, or why is it?
And these are the
questions that seem to me
you took on fearlessly in that book
with an amazing amount of composure.
You were just trying to figure it out.
Maybe you could say a little bit
about what you were
thinking as you wrote it.
- As a true American, you see,
that's the only way I knew
how to approach it, you know?
Being nice to everybody, making
sure not to insult anybody,
but trying to figure
this strange thing out.
And then I found out,
and that's partly where the
title of the book comes from.
This was not America, you know?
This was not me, you know,
trying to negotiate something
that's easily understood,
because it's not something
that's easily understood.
And why, back then, 25 years ago,
I was trying to understand why someone
who had hidden Jewish children
still had them after the war,
still had those children in his garret
and wouldn't let them out.
What the hell was that?
You know, what is that?
You know? And that's
insanity in a certain way.
But if you're Polish, not at all.
I mean, that's the way a lot of people
had to deal with this.
And anyway, so yeah, that's
the inspiration for...
So my answer back then from
Robert Jay Lifton was trauma.
They were traumatized by
what they had experienced,
what they had seen of Jews dying.
And here comes Elżbieta saying,
"Nonsense. It's not what it is at all."
- Can you tell the audience a little bit
about who Elżbieta is?
- You tell.
- (giggles) Okay.
Because so much of the book
is about that relationship.
- You think as an academic
and also an artist
who has written widely about,
basically focusing most
often on anti-Semitism,
and the notion that Polish culture,
I mean, this is the opposite
of the defensive Polish culture,
that Polish culture is deeply,
at its roots, anti-Semitic.
And there's a small number of historians,
and you know them, of course,
for whom that is mostly
younger even than Elżbieta,
who's in her forties or something.
But, so that was, you know,
that was a bone of contention.
- It's very harsh.
- Huh?
- She's very harsh in that book.
- Oh, totally harsh.
Totally harsh, very harsh.
And I had to cope with that
(chuckling) as I was writing this book.
And it's all for the good.
You'll see, I mean, you know,
those of you who go on from
this and actually read the book,
you'll see, at least, it's
very interesting places.
But I'd like to explore,
I mean, this one word,
this word "trauma."
I know it's very, you told me recently,
that it's very catchy nowadays,
and everybody's talking about trauma.
Well, I mean, I did a lot
of talking about trauma,
but what is it?
I mean, I'd love to, you know,
I mean, does that seem
like a good place to go?
'Cause I have no idea what trauma is,
but I use the word all the time.
- Well, let's disentangle, I would say.
So you were looking at
collective trauma in this book.
That the witnessing of people
being murdered in front of you
was a collective trauma for the Poles.
- Right. Correct.
- And today, people might
say secondary trauma,
when you're watching somebody
else be tortured, you know,
then you're like vicariously
experiencing something.
And the other thing that is very kind of,
that is very, "popular"
isn't the right word,
but that we keep returning to a lot now,
is intergenerational
trauma, which in some sense,
your book is about all
three of these things.
Collective trauma,
(chuckles) secondary trauma,
and intergenerational trauma.
- Who knew? Who knew, right?
You know, (chuckles) once again,
I found myself by accident
getting into the most,
you know, kind of just
completely by accident,
getting into the trendiest
kind of moments, you know?
- So you're very fashionable.
- I'm very fashionable.
That's nice to know.
I'm pretty old, so it's nice
to be fashionable still.
- I mean, you kept trying to,
for me, your book was
about trying to understand.
- Yes.
- And for me, it was a
model of what historians do
is we try to understand.
You know, before we condemn or judge,
we try to make that imaginative leap
and understand what was this phenomenon,
what was happening, you know?
And you come to this idea of trauma,
and Elżbieta's like, "Trauma, shmauma.
They're all anti-Semites."
- (chuckles) That's
precisely correct, you know?
It isn't, yeah.
The root of everything is,
and one exchange that we had,
and with, I forget who it was.
It wasn't directly with her,
but how could people have
done this to people, right,
was like a question.
And she said, "No,
that's not the question."
It's like, "People did
this to Jews, not people."
And so that for me said a lot.
That, for me, helped me to understand.
And is that too elliptical?
But you know what I...
I think people can understand.
- Well, let me now,
I mean, one of the
questions your book raises,
and I, as an American,
you know, and as a Jew,
and someone who's spent
a lot of time in Poland,
you spent a lot of time, you know,
with your cohort of 1968 in America,
with activists for gay rights,
with feminist activists,
with Black activists.
You know, you're coming from a
certain kind of cosmopolitan,
internationalist sensitivity,
in which suffering,
victimization, scapegoating,
is not something that
happens only to Jews.
- Right.
- That must have inflected
how you related to Poland
when you got there,
because you're coming from an America
in which racism, first and foremost,
is directed not against
Jews, but against Blacks.
- Right. Right.
And here it's all Jews.
So, you know, I don't know.
Is that...? (chuckles)
- How did your experiences
in America, then,
working with American racism
and trying to understand it
inflect how you understood
Polish anti-Semitism?
- How did it?
Well, I thought, you
know, I came believing
that I could, you know,
transpose these experiences,
you know, directly into
the Polish situation.
But then I was told, "No,
no, no. This is not so.
This is a very different situation,
a very different history, a
very different everything."
And I came, you know, kind of naively
with this kind of naive American...
What's that book by Henry
James, where she comes to...
- Oh, right, right. Yeah.
- "Golden Bowl." It's "The
Golden Bowl," I think.
- Yeah.
You know, where she just...
You know, I came thinking,
"Oh, you know, here's
another freedom struggle."
Right? Another freedom struggle.
And that's the way I have to approach it,
you know, in a very personal way,
because, you know, and then it turned out,
you know, as everything in
Europe, (chuckles) it turns out,
certainly in Poland, above all in Poland,
no, as they say, (speaking Polish) right?
(Marci laughing)
It's layered. It's layered.
There's so many things that you don't get.
And it took me a while to figure that out.
But, you know, is that
reasonable, to say that?
I mean...
- That it's a very complicated question?
No, I found it an enormously
complicated question.
I mean, when I read your book,
I felt like you ask
all the right questions
and you articulated them so well,
and you gave the right examples,
but in the end, you didn't...
Right. There was no ultimate answer.
But I empathized with like,
yes, that was the right question.
And there's something there
we haven't quite gotten to.
- Exactly. Exactly.
And I still haven't, you know?
It's not, you know, I'm
an old man now, (chuckles)
but has wisdom accompanied that?
- I mean, the paradox in the book is that,
you know, you're there
as the American Jew,
and Elżbieta is a very self-critical Pole,
and she's gaslighting
you, (chuckles) you know,
through the whole second half of the book.
Everything you say, you know, she's like,
"But you can't really think that,"
or, "You're repressing that,'
or "You're trying not to,"
or "You're doing something circumlocutious
so as to excuse people
who shouldn't be excused."
And...
- I'm still trying to
understand, by the way.
There's words popping up that
I'm still learning how to use.
"Gaslighting," is one of them.
You know, it's not clear
to me what all that...
You know, I finally come
closer to the notion of trauma.
But gaslighting is still
pretty far from my...
- Gaslighting is new. I've
only recently used it.
But I'm using it now
in the sense of she's trying
to cause you to doubt yourself.
- Right. Right.
- Constantly critiquing
you in a way that you start
to doubt your own...
- Well, as an American Jew,
- I mean, you know, what else?
You know, any American Jewish comedians,
you know, will agree.
Yeah, what is this? I don't know.
And she knows, you know?
I have an Israeli friend who
was in the States for a while,
and maybe you know, him, Yoav Peled
And I went up to, he
was staying in a loft,
way up high in Chinatown.
And I went up to see him,
and it was a really hot day.
And, and I said, "Yoav."
This tells you something about Israelis.
I said, "Yoav, I just don't
get it. I don't understand."
And to which he responded,
"You don't understand?
I will tell you."
You know, there's only one answer.
There's only one answer, at least, so.
- So the other thing
interesting in that story
is that, you know, part of this story
is part of an international
generation of 1968.
You know, on both sides
of the Iron Curtain
and on both sides of the Atlantic,
there was an Oedipal rebellion.
There was a revolt against the parents,
against the silences and
complicities of the parents.
And one of those things
that, you know, in your case
is you have these parents
who are coming from the
Polish-Jewish intelligentsia,
who are coming from middle class families.
They speak perfect literary
Polish, and they hate the Poles.
They have nothing good
to say about the Poles.
You spent your childhood
listening to this word,
"Wojna, wojna, wojna," you
know, which is interesting,
'cause it's precisely the
word in Russian, "war,"
which is banned now in Russia,
in which everything was subsumed under.
They have nothing good
to say about the Poles.
They don't wanna, like,
the Poles all hated them.
Sometime you tell this story in the book
where you're out with your
parents on the street,
somebody hears them speaking
Polish, and they're like,
"Ah, rodacy!" Like,
"Compatriots!" you know?
And your father's like, "Ah,
rodacy. To hell with you."
Like, we're not the...
- Runs away. And runs away.
Takes his family, you know,
like protecting us, you know?
Like, "Let's get away from this person."
"Rodak." Countryman.
And he just said, "Ja mu dam rodak."
"I'll give him rodak."
And it felt like he was
gonna punch him, you know?
- And you go to Poland.
And you go to Poland to
commune with a Jewish path,
but you also go to Poland
with an openness to Poles.
You go to Poland with a
willingness to speak Polish.
You know, you go to
Poland with a willingness
to try to understand.
- They gave me this
language, so I better use it.
I mean, I was very lucky, you know?
They gave me, you know, and they lied.
They said so I could communicate.
See, I was the only kid in
Brooklyn, in that situation,
who had an active knowledge of Polish.
You know, all the kids like
me, they could understand it,
but they couldn't speak it, so.
- That's amazing. Why was that?
- (sighs) You know what they told me?
They told me so that I could speak
with my aunt and uncle in Paris.
My uncle was with my mother's
older brother. They survived.
And that's what they said,
so that you could speak to...
And not because, you know, it was worthy,
even that it was a
worthy language. Nothing.
That's what I grew up being told.
- And you, I mean, when
I see you in Poland,
you know, I feel like one
of the things we share
is we both love Poland.
Not because we don't see
what's horrible about Poland,
but there's a deep love there.
- There is.
- And a deep attachment.
It's a beautiful place
where people keep asking
fascinating questions,
and, you know, I mean,
(chuckles) they're a minority,
but some of them, (chuckles) you know?
And nowadays they're there.
Of course they're there.
Who knows? There's gonna be elections.
Maybe, maybe. Who knows?
Keep your fingers crossed.
Maybe the good guys will win, huh?
- And how much of that
reaching out to the Poles
was a rebellion against your parents?
- I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
Yeah, I mean, I rebelled against
my parents in lots of ways.
I'm not sure that was one.
'Cause my father was long
gone by then, you know?
He died 10 years before.
And I'm not sure, I'm not sure.
It was an intense desire
to see what the world...
See, it turned out wrong
for me, personally.
I didn't want to talk about
the Holocaust, you know?
I wanted to talk about the
world before the Holocaust.
You know, I wanted to talk about life.
I mean, this is the
way I talked back then.
"I wanna talk about life,
not death," you know?
I wanna, you know, find out
what this world was about
that my parents, and it seemed
like a fascinating world.
And so I became enamored of who?
Of dead Jews, you see.
And people ask me, "Well,
you know, what is the...?"
I mean, you know,
everyone has like a group.
Everyone has someone who they
define themselves against.
And, you know, I have this,
I think I tell the story in the book,
about people, about these Chicanos.
You don't use the word Chicanos anymore,
but back then, we used the word Chicanos,
Mexican Americans, who talked
about how they had this land
that's today northern New
Mexico, rather northern Mexico
and southern New Mexico,
that the mythical name for it is Aztlán.
Aztlán, A-Z-T-L-A-N.
It's a beautiful concept.
It's a beautiful thing.
And I got really into
that back in Seattle,
because a lot of these
people talked about Aztlán.
And then I suddenly realized,
(chuckles) you know,
that Aztlán is like the world
that (speaking Yiddish) comes from,
you know, because it's at the same time,
it's beautiful, you know?
And at the same time, it's both
beautiful and impoverished,
totally impoverished, you know?
And who are these Jews?
You know, where are these Jews from?
You know, and it's funny,
'cause that's not who my parents
were, of course. (chuckles)
But this notion of, "Yeah, we are Jews,
and this is our homeland, okay?"
And we all have homelands, of course.
But my homeland, when I went back there,
was dead Jews, it turned out, so.
- But you also met some live Jews.
and Stajek and Krejewski
and Kostak Gebert and Anika.
- Yeah, and Paweł Śpiewak,
who just passed on.
A wonderful guy, a wonderful man.
You know, he was head
of the Jewish Historical
Institute for some years.
Anyway. Yeah, yeah.
And some of these people were,
you know, I think they
saw me as totally naive.
I remember Paweł saying to
me at one point, you know,
because I was into running
back then, you know,
and no one, you know, people
would sic their dogs on me.
(Marci laughing)
You know, I was especially, I
liked in the, what was that?
In the Royal Gardens. What's that?
- Łazienki.
- Łazienki. I used to love
to run through Łazienki.
- I love running in Łazienki.
- Well, you were, you know,
I was out there, you know,
and people would sic their dogs
on me, you know, and laugh.
And they even laughed.
They would say, "Well, what
the hell is this guy doing?
You know, running?"
So, yeah.
What was that an answer to? I've lost it.
- Oh, the live Jews who you met,
who were working through
what it meant to be Jewish.
- Yeah, yeah.
So Paweł said, so when he heard it,
when I told him about that, he said,
"Oh, the American wants to
live forever," you know?
"The American... Yeah, I get it.
So the American... Yeah."
- And what did you learn from them?
How did that group of people
who were connected to Solidarity,
who were carrying out a Jewish revival,
who did not grow up in that Jewish,
specifically, traditionally Jewish milieu,
and were trying to discover it as adults,
what did you learn from them?
- Well, learn from them.
I mean, they were just like me, you see,
because I didn't, you know,
I didn't grow up speaking
Yiddish, you know?
I wanted to have, I wished I had.
So in a certain way, that
brought me very close to them.
And on the other hand, you
know, they were digging.
They were digging, and they
were creating something new.
And that was really
extraordinary, you know?
I mean, what did I learn from them?
You know, it's hard to
answer that question,
you know, what did I learn?
- 'Cause they were a certain
kind of mediating bridge.
There were the dead
Jews who you never met.
There were the Jews in Brighton
Beach who you grew up with.
And then there were these
Jews who were your generation,
who you were encountering
in this place where,
had things been different,
you might have been them.
You might have grown up there.
- Oh, easily, easily. That's right.
That's right. So, I don't know.
I mean, I've often thought
I could have been them,
but I also could have grown
up in Israel, you know?
My father had tickets to go there.
I mean, he was given, this
guy gave him, you know,
and he, my father thought,
"Hmm, should we go?
Nah, we won't go."
I mean, you know, it was that...
I sometimes consider my life, you know,
just being, if only, if only, you know?
There's, I mean, not only
did I not have a homeland,
but who were these people, you know?
They were Polish Jews,
but they also could have been Israelis,
I mean, in that way, you know?
Anyway, I think I'm...
Yeah, does that make sense?
- It does.
And you've spent a lot
of your life, you know,
working through a relationship
with a brother who died
before you were born.
- Yes.
- Why don't you, I'll let you
tell the audience this story.
- The story is a story.
My father (chuckles) had the
extraordinary good fortune,
you know, Jews love irony,
the extraordinary good
fortune to have gotten married
at the end of 1939 in Warsaw.
And shortly thereafter, you know,
they immediately made a
child, he and this woman.
Not my mother, I mean, he and this woman.
And as far as I can tell, at
the age of this boy, Michał,
they called him Michał,
but there's all these different words,
because he was named after
my grandfather, Moisha,
as was I.
Or was I named after him?
That was never clear.
But at the age of roughly
two-and-a-half, he was killed.
He died.
Now, it was Elżbieta who
helped me really understand
the most probable way he died.
And the most probable way he
died was they were hiding.
My father was gone. My father
was not in their hiding place.
And we're talking 1942, right, after July,
after the Aktion and all that.
And so how did this happen?
Well, most probably, of course, who knows?
You know, they were in a
hiding place, and the child,
who was about two-and-a-half,
made some sounds, you know?
And his mom was holding
him, and his mom killed him.
His mom smothered him.
That was a documented, you know...
There's enough documentation
of stuff like this
to make that the most probable.
Although not, you know, some
Nazi could have grabbed him
and smashed his head against the wall.
That's possible too. I've
thought of that sometimes.
I mean, you know, not nice.
And at a certain point, (chuckles)
yeah, you told me, you
warned me against dybbuk,
but I'll say at a certain point
late, you know, in my life,
I mean, relatively late.
I was living, my friends were printers
who printed for the "revolution,"
and I was staying at their
place on the Lower East Side.
And it felt that inside
me was something strange,
was something that's...
Now, you have to understand,
you know, dybbuks,
you know, there are dybbuks and dybbuks.
There's the nice dybbuk of the play,
but then there's bad dybbuks,
which is what they usually are.
Like, I read about one
dybbuk, someone asked him,
"Why'd you come back?"
"Well, I came back, you
know, I had to come back
because I slept with boys," you know?
And, you know, so there's
usually something,
except in the play, there's
usually something bad associated
that they have to redress.
And how do you redress a
two-and-a-half-year-old child?
And that's what I experienced.
I experienced rage.
Rage, because, you know,
"Why did you do this to me?
How did I die?"
You know? "What was this? What was this?"
And so, you know, and it was in my belly,
this kind of turning.
Yeah, turning is really
the best word for it.
You told me not to, but
I'm talking about it.
But I'm done, I think.
I mean, it's very, very...
And it pursued me. I mean he pursued me.
I mean, for a while.
I guess it was a sense of, you know,
"Why did you," meaning plural,
"why did you do this to me?"
How did this happen?" you know?
And it's like this rage,
this kind of, you know,
two-year-old-rage, you know,
what that might be like.
I mean, you have kids.
(Marci laughing)
I had two-year-old rage,
"Because you killed me."
Anyway, so there you go.
And that came out of, and
that's in this book too.
- Oh, there's a lot
about him in this book.
And I was at the
performance in Krasnogruda,
that maybe, which was extraordinary.
Maybe you could tell the audience
about this kind of musical
artistic resolution.
- Yeah, that was what sent
him back to wherever he...
That performance, I mean, was...
We created this performance
with the, what's his name,
with the musician?
What's his name?
- Was it Michał?
- No, it wasn't Michał.
No, it was someone... (sighs)
Oh, he's wonderful.
He's a wonderful...
- I know you know who
you're talking about.
I'll look it up. You keep talking.
- Yeah. All right.
But anyway, and the of two of us,
he did the music, and I did
various texts that I dug up
about trying to deal
with this dybbuk memory.
And it was like a performance
we did at Krasnogruda.
And, oh, what's his name?
He's still performing.
He's a wonderful musician.
He's a solo guitar player,
among other things.
And so, anyway, this
performance at Krasnogruda,
Krosnogruda is just is a
wonderful, is in a magical place
in the far northeast of Poland
where magical things happen,
(Marci giggles)
and one of them was this.
And they have, you know,
they bring people together
to talk about the stuff
we're talking about, partly,
but years and years later than, you know,
what we've been talking about here.
But anyway, that years and years later
is what allowed me to let go of,
or maybe he (chuckles)
allowed himself to let go.
Who knows? Maybe, you know,
but something happened.
I'm no longer possessed, thank goodness.
- But you were very
empathetic to that possession
or that intimacy, I mean...
- How can you not be empathetic?
A two-and-a-half-year-old. Come on.
I mean, what am I supposed
to, you know, curse him?
It's enough that he cursed me, you know?
- No, Elżbieta's, you
know, probable scenario.
- Hey, where are you?
Hey, hey, hey, hey. Hey, hey, hey.
Hey.
Technical, technical.
Are you back?
- Yeah, I'm here. (giggles)
- Hey. Yay.
- Hello.
- Okay, what was I gonna say?
- Okay, so, no, the scene of the death,
'cause Michał Głowiński, who is another,
who was a child also in the Warsaw ghetto
and wrote a book around the
same time in the nineties,
"Czarne Sezony" which I then
translated into English.
And there's a scene he
describes, you know,
of a baby in a cellar
where everybody is hiding.
They don't wanna be taken
for the deportations.
The baby keeps making noise.
People are saying, "You
have to smother the baby,
otherwise we're all gonna be caught."
I use that scene in my
undergraduate seminars,
and I say, "You know, what are
the ethics of this situation?
Do you smother the baby?"
You know, there are no innocent
choices in this scenario.
- No, of course not. And you do.
But, I have to say, my
situation was even tougher,
because this was not a baby.
- Right.
- This was, you know, a kid
who already knew some language, you know?
So that's, I would just add that.
And yeah.
- And you say in the book that
when your first son was born,
you policed his birth. (chuckles)
(Michael chuckling)
So that there would be no further dybbuks.
- I was with my wife who was,
you know, we were together.
I mean, we were together.
She was giving birth and I
was watching her over her,
and she was out of it, you know?
You know, she's out of it.
This child is coming out,
this baby's coming out.
And I did something, you know?
I just wanted to make sure
that there wasn't anything around
that was gonna grab into him, you know,
because that would be a logical thing.
Dybbuk, you know, moves outta
me and goes into my son.
(chuckles) I did it this
little ritual or something.
I don't even remember really what,
but that was a concern of mine.
I said, "You're not getting this one.
You're not getting this one. Uh huh."
So this is, I talk about
generational, you know?
- Yeah.
- And this is generational.
- No, a lot of, I mean, a
lot of our questions now
about what led to this
anthropological catastrophe in Russia
have kind of gone back to
intergenerational trauma.
The kind of, the idea of
things that were not processed,
that were not talked about,
- In Russia. Yeah.
- Right, that keep like
experiences under Stalinism
that were silent,
that one generation passed
on to the next generation.
- There's nothing, I mean,
that's going on in Russia today
that can compare to what
happened under Stalinism.
You know, it's not
proportional. It's not right.
I mean, it's 3 million, what is it?
3 million Ukrainians starved
to death, purposely? (chuckles)
You know, I think that,
you know, but anyway.
- The idea is that what is
not somehow worked through
or spoken about, or that there's some kind
of intergenerational
transmission of trauma, you know?
- Okay.
- That's been, I think, where
a lot of the discussion is.
We're running out of time,
but I wanna get to some of the questions.
You know, one of them,
the first one from Alexandra Kolojeska,
I think I know the answer to,
but I will let you answer it.
"Was it possible to detach the personal
and generational trauma
from the academic aspect
while you are writing
and researching books?
Did you feel like you could
somehow compartmentalize
your own biography and
your family relations
as you were being a scholar in Poland?"
- (sighs) Short answer, no.
There's, you know, I could discuss stuff.
I mean, there's more to
it, obviously, but no.
I mean, my being in Poland
was all about, you know,
going where my parents had been,
I mean, and feeling the feelings.
And, you know, for example, Nalewki.
Nalewki, that's where, I
mean, before the war, Nalewki,
not today's Nalewki, but
before the war Nalewki,
was where my mother lived and
where they had their business.
And I would go, you know, the
addresses were all screwed up.
So, but I wasn't, yeah.
You see, because
originally I went to Poland
to work on Yitskhok Peretz,
you know, the great Yiddish
writer, the great Yiddish sage.
And I dropped that,
because I thought I needed
to write about Poland.
So, anyway.
- Oh, somebody here saying
it's Raphael Rogiński
- Oh, okay. Hi.
- No, who was the musician.
- The person talking to you like this,
this is hearsay from somebody I...
- No, no, that's who I was
thinking of too, was Raphael.
I think it was Raphael
Rogiński at that performance
in Krasnogruda.
- Ah, oh, is that who's talking now?
- No, somebody else wrote in questions
that that was the name of musician.
No, that's the person I
have that I'm thinking of.
- And I sure wish he was out
there, but I don't think he is.
- Yeah. No, I don't think
he's on Zoom right now.
But no, this is the name I
also forgot, but I know like...
- Wonderful. I can't praise him.
I mean, he is a wonderful guy.
- No, it was extraordinary.
Okay, let me give you one more question.
This is a question about,
there are other children of
survivors who grew up hearing,
you know, "Never again," and,
"The Poles are anti-Semites,"
you know, and, "That's a graveyard."
How would you speak to other children
whose parents were survivors,
or grandchildren of survivors?
Should they go back to Poland?
How would you encourage them?
How would you explain it?
- Absolutely I would encourage them.
Let go. Let go of all your
bullshit, of all your hatreds.
You know, really.
I mean, you know, 'cause people like me
were instructed in hatred of Poles.
I mean, and no.
Look, back when I was in Poland,
it was a place that was
a little easier to like
than the Poland of today.
So, you know, with its right-wing
nationalist everything,
but yeah.
But you will find, go to Poland.
You'll find people you
can talk to about it,
and people that are fascinating.
Yeah.
- I mean, now there's a
right-wing government,
but it's still a divided society.
There's still that, like, there's
still that half of Poland.
- Half of, well, it's not...
See, what I explain to people
is that it's just like us.
- Right. Exactly.
- But there's more of the bad guys
and here there's more of the good guys.
- (laughing) Yeah, the
percentage kind of like...
Yeah, the percentage is
a topic for discussion,
But we could also like ask,
look at how Poland has
taken in Ukrainian refugees.
It's a moment.
- Yes, yes. Absolutely, absolutely.
I mean, God, it is beautiful.
It's beautiful, and it shows, you know...
And then, you know, every
now and then, you know,
because I have a Black son,
every now and then, you know, I think,
"What if they were African?" (chuckles)
How quickly...?
But that's neither here
or there. But, you know.
- And you brought him to Poland.
- What?
- You brought your son to Poland.
- Yeah, but it's not
exactly a place for him.
- No.
- Especially not now.
There's so many pieces of my life
that are unintegrated still, that, yeah.
- We're just about out of time,
but I wanna give you a chance,
like having gone through
this, it's a remarkable book.
I wanna recommend. It's very easy to read.
It's very conversational.
You know, it's not, there
are scholarly references,
but it's not stilted in academic,
you know, it's very kind of contestatory,
you know, and passionate in places.
But it's also about searching
for a way forward, you know?
And it's about trying from
all of this trauma, you know,
to see, is there a light?
Is there a way forward? Is
there a way we can understand?
- Oh that's where my origins
in the sixties comes in,
you know, because nowadays,
everything's darker, you know?
And for the young people, too.
And that's so sad, because
back then it had to get better.
And what's more, you were there
to make sure it's gonna get better.
That's what the sixties were, you know?
And today, it's problematic,
that kind of attitudes.
Yeah, but I was totally...
I believed that despite everything,
we, whatever that meant,
we would prevail, you know?
So it would be nice if it
was the opposite, you know?
If I had started in a very negative place,
and then in my age, now,
you know what I'm saying,
if I was vindicated in some way.
But unfortunately things are
just getting darker. (chuckles)
- Oh. How do you feel now
about our potential to prevail?
- How do I feel now about what?
- Our potential to prevail.
- Potential?
Well, you know, maybe you
can beat the Russians.
I mean, you know, maybe the Ukrainians,
maybe they can do it.
I mean, that's not out of the question.
God knows. But that would be incredible.
And that would be kind of the thing
we were dreaming of back then.
I mean, you know, the
forces of evil beaten down.
I don't know.
It is not out of the question,
let's put it that way.
And God knows, you know, it's possible.
It's possible.
You know, deep down,
I'm not sure I believe
that's gonna happen.
How do you feel?
- I wanna hold on to that possibility.
- Good.
- I also, like you, I brought
children in this world,
and since I brought
children into this world,
I have to believe that the forces of evil
can be beaten down.
- Good.
- I'm gonna let our audience go.
Michael, thank you so much.
I wish I could have seen you in person.
I hope I will soon, but
it was lovely to see you
even over zoom.
- It was lovely. Yeah.
- I hope to see the whole
family again in Krasnogruda.
- Yeah, that would be lovely.
We'll see, we'll see.
But it was lovely seeing you,
and this whole conversation
has been very good.
I think. I don't know.
We'll see.
- No, it was wonderful.
Thank you so much, Michael. Take care.
Thank you to our audience.
- Peace to all.
- Bye.